let's stay with the war in Ukraine now
and a source close to the White House
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
says he has held confidential talks with
senior Russian officials aimed at
reducing the risk of a broader War
meanwhile Russian forces are conducting
new counter-offensives in the dombas and
are preparing for a new battle in her
son well joining me now is our defense
and security analyst Michael Clarke at
hi to you Michael thanks for joining us
so these reports of potential talks
between the U.S and Russia on the use of
strategic nuclear weapons how different
is that from the back channels that we
know exist already regarding nuclear
weapons between Washington and Moscow
yeah I mean these back channels you know
take place all the time these sort of
communications are fairly standard so
Jake Sullivan is the National Security
advisor in in Washington and so he's an
important Insider he's an important
character in this respect and Jake so
I'm quite a youngish guy actually but
he's very influential with Joe Biden and
the team team and the man he's talking
to in a sense is his counterpart in the
Kremlin which is ojikov uh Euro usikov
and there he is on the left again senior
man he's not a minister he's not
communist not the defense minister but
if you talk to usikov then you know that
Putin will hear it and what they are
talking about I think is make sure that
there are no accidents in all crises you
know accidents tend to happen Cuba
crisis 80 years ago this this last month
just uh passed was full of near misses
full of accidents and so what they're
saying is let's make sure that there are
no accidents but also they're saying I'm
fairly sure don't misunderstand us the
Americans will be saying to the Russian
through zakov don't even think about
nuclear use don't even think about it
because we've gained it out we know what
we will do and we will react very very
strongly they may specify what they'll
do maybe they won't but it's a way of
saying to the Russians keeping the
pressure on the Russians don't even
think about escalation that you are
gladly talking about I mean Putin's
speeches are full of escalatory rhetoric
and the Americans are just saying tone
it down and to be honest in the last
couple of weeks some of the nuclear
rhetoric coming out of Russia does seem
to have been toned down so I suspect
these talks may be having the desired
effect certainly sobering stuff
nonetheless that we're even discussing
nuclear weapons isn't it now let's talk
about what's happening on the
battlefield uh the latest in the Eastern
dombas Michael there's been some pretty
harrowing reports coming up yeah lots of
big stuff happening yeah yeah I mean the
the big battle is that the ukrainians
are attacking between svatovi and
criminal they're trying to break that
line which the Russians are holding the
p-66 highway between those two places
that's a key battle but right in the
middle of that between svatovi and
criminal at makifa the Russians are
counter-attacking quite strongly so it's
quite a small place for Kiefer but
they've pushed out to about 15
kilometers about 25 kilometers north to
south and it's quite a big
counter-attack the ukrainians in a sense
of let them come they've gone to The
High Ground west of makiefka and they're
now out artillery barraging the Russians
but that's a pretty big attack and the
Russians are trying to break this
Stranglehold which the ukrainians have
established over svatova criminal and
the p-66 very important Highway further
south of bakmut the Wagner group who are
the The Mercenaries who work for the
Kremlin they've been attacking Bachman
for about four weeks now very very
powerful attacks but they still haven't
taken it and we know from what's been
happening at back mud they've got
convicts in the front line they've got
mobilized men behind them and regulars
behind them and the regulars in the
third line are known as the barrier
troops and their job is to shoot any of
the convicts or the mobilized men who
Retreat this is what they used to do at
Stalingrad in the second world war shoot
anyone who Retreats that's the way
they're fighting a backward and they're
losing an enormous number of men and
they still haven't taken it so both that
uh in on the p-66 highway and the bakmut
the Russians are losing a lot of people
and at pavlifka even further south near
Donetsk the whole of the most of the 155
Marine Brigade the Russia 155 Marine
Brigade looks as if it's it's suffered
terribly it's been almost wiped out and
there's a lot of comments on Russian uh
channels back channels and their social
media about all of this the Russian
media won't cover it the currently says
oh we've lost about two percent no they
haven't they've lost well over 50
percent of the 155th Marine Brigade so
it's really hurting them and what is the
latest in the southern city of Hassan
we've been waiting for a big Ukrainian
counter-offensive there for weeks now
but certainly it seems like things are
moving yeah it's changing what the
Russians are doing they are moving to
the Eastern side of the danipro river
and so they're getting out of Curson
City but they're leaving troops behind
both mobilized troops in dug in
positions and reportedly a lot of
regular troops in civilian clothes and
there's a sort of Reign of Terror
appeared apparently taking place now
there's only about 60 000 people still
in person 300 000 originally about 60
000 now
and they're picking people up off the
streets and what the Russians seem to be
trying to do is to encourage the
ukrainians when they attack us and which
they will to turn it into a series of
Street battles in which it will appear
that the ukrainians are shooting fellow
ukrainians and Russian TV Crews have
turned up in the last 48 hours in
Kirsten to film all of this so they're
setting themselves up for what looks
like a very nasty as it were a battle of
propaganda as well as a battle and
meanwhile the the ukrainians are moving
against novakovka that's important
because novakov controls the access to
Kirsten and the important damage Nova
kokovca that we've talked about many
times that dam is critical both to the
possibility of flooding further
Downstream if the Russians blow the dam
it will flood the valley right through
to Kirsten I mean it would take about 19
hours for the flood waters to get to the
but the uh the Black Sea but they will
get there but also it will cut off the
canal the main Canal that runs from the
dam right down to Crimea to supply water
to Crimea so it's a big thing to do but
if the ukrainians look as if they are
about to take no the betting is the
Russians will blow the dam and then
there's a new situation meanwhile 60 60
000 civilians are in the fireplace down
there Michael thank you